[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
john iran does a great job the sports
business journal media reporter
on uh these numbers with the super bowl
and john joins us on short notice
were the super bowl numbers down and if
so why john
uh dan i didn't realize you're such a
prima donna 100 million
i would go on for a bag of peanuts
so were the numbers down yeah the super
bowl numbers were down um
uh i wasn't surprised the the regular
season numbers were down about seven
percent the super bowl numbers were down
generally about seven or eight percent
and i think that there are
there are probably a billion reasons why
uh the game was not competitive
which is a a main reason i think it was
a the biggest score differential
second biggest score definitely until in
the last like 18 years i think was a
stat that i saw
um and for me it just didn't have a big
game feel
i there was there was no super bowl week
leading into into the game
the the stadium had a 20 000 people in a
68 000 people
uh stadium so there wasn't this raucous
crowd
going on there and i don't know anybody
that went to a super bowl party yeah
uh you know there was just no this to me
this game was basically a game that
ended the nfl season
as opposed to a super bowl that would
get you know my wife and daughters
interested in
in watching it what about streaming
numbers and how do those factor in the
overall
numbers the totality yeah i mean the
the the greatest thing about cbs's
release that they put out today dan was
a
they talked about you know an overall
number and they got right into streaming
but
yeah you you can tell like streaming
every single year is going to set a new
record i mean that's that's sort of
the the trend of the media business i
think the
streaming numbers were for an average
mid and audience which is
most comparable to a tv viewing number i
think it was about six million people
streaming 5.7 million
uh and that that what that set of record
um it was a it's a big uh point of
emphasis for the nfl
for and for the the networks and i
expect those for the next several years
to the
the release to say you know all-time
high for streaming do you think
in our lifetime we'll see a super bowl
on somebody
like uh apple or amazon
you know one of these you know big
carriers that come in
i i you know in our lifetime is a long
time hopefully but i know i i i don't i
think the
the nfl uh currently has a media
strategy
where it wants to be available to the
most people possible
and that's always going to be broadcast
tv and and so i i
i think that what we will see is um
you know the super bowl going to like an
amazon prime or or
or youtube but it'll be simulcast on
there
and and the the main thing will be on on
broadcast television but
i i think that we are a very very long
way away from broadcast television not
bringing in the most viewers which is
the only thing that the nfl wants
how do they account for those watching
the super bowl in a bar
and in this case this year didn't watch
in a bar
all right i'm gonna try to explain this
for your audience it doesn't get too in
the weeds but they they
they have something called the out of
home uh number and so they they
they count the people that are watching
in bars at friends houses and the people
if you're a nielsen rated household you
walk around basically with an electronic
beeper
and it picks it it picks up not the
video but the audio so that they they're
making sure
this is all an ad for advertising they
want to make sure that people are
actually listening to the ads
and so the the number that cbs put out
one of the reasons that they were
supposed to put it out yesterday they
put it out today one of the reasons they
delayed it is because they wanted to
make sure they got the out of home
number
baked into that that number considering
the pandemic
did the nfl have as good a year as
other sports or better year than other
sports yeah
the nfl is king and and and this year
even though the ratings were down
proved it and i i think that if if you
take a look at uh
the biggest story that i'm covering dan
is about the uh the next round of of nfl
rights
and what networks are gonna gonna get
them and so
the ratings were down about seven
percent uh it was a tough year all
all the way around and you better
believe that nbc is gonna
double its payout cbs is going to double
its payout fox and espn are going to pay
really significant increases every every
single tv network
is going to be paying about 2 billion
per year
for nfl rights going forward so well you
know
where the ratings down this year yeah a
little bit but tv networks still
view the nfl as just the biggest
programming the best programming just
the king and that's
they're not going to lose that anytime
soon how valuable
would peyton manning be on the open
market if tony romo is worth 17 million
tony romo is worth 17 million tony romo
is uh
that was a specific point in time where
espn needed somebody there were two
networks that that were going after him
you have the rights deal coming up uh
and so it was it was this perfect storm
for tony
that he was able to leverage if if
payton were to come come
in into that sort of scenario yeah he
would be getting
you know i i could easily see something
between 10 to 15 million i mean he's
a bonafide star that that uh that does
well on television
but unless there's that competition
unless there's that you know the rights
deal
going forward the market is nowhere near
15 million dollars i mean
the the tony romo contract is like a
unicorn contract oh my gosh
i know that's a whole lot does he help
ratings
does it show that he somehow boost
ratings
um i think that he helps in terms of p
that they're only a very few people uh
john madden tony romo
that that people uh stick with bad games
longer because he's doing it and if you
talk to one of the cbs executives
they talk they use this metric where if
they're going in an
airport people talk about tony romo they
identify tony romo with
cbs and they think that it's a great
sort of marketing look
for the nfl on cbs to have somebody like
tony any chance that jim nance leaves
cbs no i can't you know with this better
than i do
dan i i can't i can't see a scenario
where he leaves
cbs i i i would imagine espn would be
willing
to talk to him i don't think those that
there really have been any serious talks
there
and i i just i don't see jim nance
leaving well jim probably trying to
create some leverage so
he could get a 17 million dollar a year
contract for this
knows how to create leverage john great
to talk to you as always thanks for
joining us
absolutely thanks for having me aye
that's john iran does a great job sports
business journal
media reporter there